etwas verpufft
[Musik]
wir haben vorhin in einem beitrag gehört
eine australische krankenschwester hat
über jahre hinweg sterbende begleitet
und erfahren was menschen die dem tod
ins auge blicken
am meisten freuen nämlich nicht den mut
gehabt zu haben das eigene leben zu
leben
wie kann es also gelingen ein erfülltes
leben zu leben mit sich und anderen im
einklang und doch fest bestimmt zu sein
der renommierte kinderarzt remo largo
hat dazu dieses buch geschrieben das
passende leben eine angenehm
differenzierte analyse jeder mensch ist
einzigartig
ein unikat ein individuum dieses zum
strahlen zu bringen
ein leben zu leben dass einem entspricht
davon träumen wo die meisten der rund
siebeneinhalb milliarden auf diesem
planeten
doch krieg armut hunger machen diesen
traum in weiten teilen der erde zunichte
und wie sieht es in unserer
wohlstandsgesellschaft haus schaffen wir
es ein passendes leben zu leben
zufrieden sind wir nicht
die meisten dürften nach mehr und mehr
wir glauben dass wir in köln startet
2012 regulator hat 40 jahre lang hat
wissenschaftler und entwicklungs
pädiater den menschen studiert und weiß
nur zu gut karriere um jeden preis
konkurrenz stress sind heute schon fast
die norm das gegenteil eines passenden
lebensraum gegen wir waren fleißig zu
reden überhaupt sondern einfach dort wo
roke hat oder aus indium trotz
realisiert klingt nach minimalismus nein
kontert lago das menschsein lago sagt
den gesellschaftlichen zwängen den kampf
an
fordert ein sofortiges umdenken muss ich
habe viele was passiert wenn die kultur
zu bewahren wurde hier sehen videos zu
einer disco menschen zwei jahren hat es
gibt jetzt gibt es ihn das interessiert
sind sogar hindernisbahn die schönsten
autos
er forderte deshalb die erwachsenen sie
müssten sich von konventionen befreien
aussteigen
voraussetzung dafür sei nicht anderen
gerecht werden zu wollen sondern sich
selber
sie könnte es nur noch wenn sie uns in
kordel vorstellen kann
das eine sieht bedürfnis sind und anders
sind
wie wichtig sind einem beispielsweise
selbstverwirklichung sicherheit
anerkennung jeder gewichtet
grundbedürfnisse anders wenn man seine
kämpfe und auch seine kompetenzen ist
man den passenden leben ein ganzes stück
näher
die sich kompetenzen entwickeln werde in
der kindheit verhandelt maz entscheidend
seien die rahmenbedingungen für
[Musik]
hauptaufgaben adresse ruft
ausstellungsteam individualität in
ställe und die textur hinter sich bevor
ihn zu reden und sie stand frage was hat
die tochter und reisen wohin sie
begriffen was hat diese fähigkeit und
damit besucher tiere sondern sie zum
botschafter dass er sich selber sehr
wichtig und es geht nur darum sind wie
das sehr verbreitet ist jetzt ziemlich
gezögert lago verpasst im voerder waren
eine klare abfuhr
denn werde ein kind zu sehr gefüttert
wird es nicht größer sondern bloß ich
auch sein lerntempo für sie das kind
ganz allein finden
das im spital und reduziert und eine
strukturell bedingte von lernen lassen
statt deren stärken stärken und
schwächen akzeptieren
nicht nur ein kindes sondern auch im
erwachsenenalter
doch nur menschen die miteinander
vertraut sind könnten geben sei die
schwächen tolerieren so lago er plädiert
für lebensgemeinschaften statt anonymer
massengesellschaft für einen wandel die
er in zoologischen gärten statt findet
gilt am kreuz tragenden irgendwann
signet didier hand bestimmte bedürfnisse
und jetzt in dubai zu verwursten piräus
und genau definiert er träumt von einem
miteinander von funktionierenden
sozialen strukturen von solidarität von
menschen die ihre individualität in
übereinstimmung mit der umwelt leben
klingt einleuchtend
trotz allem ein passendes leben in allen
bereichen wieder zeit zu führen bleibt
ein traum im leben wirklich weiterkommen
heißt sich selber näher kommen
[Musik]
remoulade schäbigen kommenden sonntag zu
gast in der sternstunde